okay let's go to the four one three area
code for 1/3 of course the original area
code of the David Pakman show out in
western Massachusetts who's calling from
four one three today hi there David
Pakman meet Joe I'm originally from East
Longmeadow Maslin live in Asbury Park
New Jersey alright yeah I have a bunch
of topics may I give you a little
insight on how I think with this
authoritarianism thing goes on reminds
me of how my paternal great-grandfather
served in the White Army for the Romanov
family reminds me of how the Bolshevik
uprising started and eventually created
the Red Army and the Soviet Union which
is why I do not want any Stalinist
leaders in this country ever being
Donald Trump and the other part is I
also have family that were French
Huguenots and Dutch reformists that came
to New Netherlands which is modern-day
Greenpoint Brooklyn and Long Island and
New Jersey right now Joe if I may for a
second because you're totally shot out
of a cannon today and I love it but I
would love to maybe drill down on a
couple of these things you said
something interesting which was you
don't want any Stalinists like Trump in
what way is Trump a Stalinist I find
that with the way he's trying to be all
stiff and stern and he's trying to make
it his way or the highway or he's gonna
get rid of you like grab you out of his
offices like if he doesn't like you he's
gonna try and fire you just like through
a tweet yeah I mean that's definitely
authoritarian and I understand you know
stolen was authoritarian and Trump has
authoritarian tendencies I just don't
know how to stall it it seems Trump is
more of like a corporate statist from
from what I'm observing but I don't know
that Stalin's the right analogy
necessarily but for me on an American
level yeah this is very this is very
authoritarian it is reminds me it
reminds me of Stalin on an American how
do I say level and so and then on the
other end he also attacks people of
other religions and so he pretends to
cater to people of other religions that
are
you know non-muslim and all that and
he's very Pro super religious
conservative Christian group and for me
I'm a Protestant I was baptized in
Longmeadow mass right and I was also got
my Bible and Isan though I'm a First
Congregational and he doesn't know but
okay maybe but joke back to what you
said so the religious element that seems
not at all Stalin like right like what
at you that likes don know but he's he's
trying to cater to his base and try and
create his own cult if I may yeah
all right no I think I see what you're
saying I just think that if the traits
are authoritarianism and catering to
your base and cult-like behavior I just
don't think I go to Stalin because
fundamentally Trump and stallin want
totally different systems of government
but I appreciate the call and it's
always great to hear from folks from the
four one three area code even if you're
in Asbury Park where I once played a
show in the band I was in in New York in
New York City we played a show in Asbury
Park Bruce Springsteen's home or
whatever I guess it's considered his
home who knows if that's even really
true